mais d'abord nous allons consacrer une
grande page à la crise agricole qui
monte dans le pays la colleur des
agriculteurs continue contre les normes
environnementales avec de nombreux
blocages routiers et d'ailleurs
l'information de la matinée c'est qu'une
personne est décédé sur un blocage
routier organisé par des agriculteurs
dans le département de lariège alors
hier soir et bien pour essayer de
résoudre cette crise Gabriel Atal a
rencontré les syndicats de la FNSEA des
jeunes agriculteurs il leur a des
annonces rapides et pour illustrer ce
débat et bien nous sommes allés à la
rencontre d'un jeune agriculteur dans le
Bassin parisien un agriculteur
pleinement engagé dans son métier mais
qui doit faire face à l'instabilité des
prix à la lourdeur de certaines règles
sans oublier les taxes unortrait signé
Jérôme
Rabier depuis 7 ans Quentin Le Guillou
est un agriculteur à son compte heureux
propriétaire de 180 haectares à la
frontière entre leur aoir et les
Yvelines ici il cultive des céréales blé
maïs colza orge ou encore sorgo avec un
engagement total je me suis installé du
coup hiver
2016-27 26 ans
euh on va parler grand chiffre mais
entre entre 700 et et 900000 € donc
c'est l'investissement d'une vie 180
hactares du matériel un corps de ferme
des terres pour pour exploiter donc oui
on s'alourdit sur une vie donc derrière
bah quand on s'installe il faut voir sur
de l'avenir donc moi j'ai vu sur de
l'avenir sur
l'amélioration de mon exploitation ici
pas de labour des terres Quentin Le
Guillou travaille en semi-direct
souscouvert une technique agroécologique
qui a fait ses preuves pour faire face
aux aléas climatiques ça c'est la ici je
vais semer un maïs en avril donc pour
protéger mon sol tout l'hiver j'ai fait
le choix d'y mettre moutarde férole la
moutarde tarde elle elle capte l'azote
dans le sol elle le prend dans la plante
elle le relargue au moment de la
destruction donc moi là mois de mars je
vais venir je vais tout broyer je vais
laisser ça va faire un paillage au sol
l'avantage de faire ça c'est que j'ai un
bénéfice sur les engrais et c'est
surtout que j'ai un léger gain face au
face aux aléas climatiques notamment les
fortes sécheresses des choix
d'agriculture qui nécessitent d'investir
de s'équiper mais avec toujours
au-dessus de la tête une épée de
damoclesè et des règles qui changent on
essaie de changer on essaie de
s'améliorer mais de jour en jour bah on
s'en prend des nouveautés on a des
fiscalités qui changent on a voilà il y
a eu sur l'automne les RPD ou finalement
alors les RPD c'est les redevances sur
les pollutions diffuses qui étaient
tombé on s'est dit on va se prendre une
augmentation augmentation 20 %. ça est
pas prévu dans le budget de l'année bon
bah 20 % de plus sur les taxes sur les
l'utilisation des produits une taxe
aussi en plus sur l'eau je suis pas
contre payer ces taxesl si derrière
j'arrive à les trouver soit sur de
l'accompagnement soit sur de l'aide à
l'investissement ou une aide pour
améliorer sa ferme c'est juste que bah
des fois on a du mal à vraiment
retrouver toutes ces toutes ces taxes là
qu'on nous prend donc voilà il faut
savoir vivre avec tout ça il faut se
préparer à l'avenir et des fois on nous
aide pas vraiment à voir sur la vision
sur du long terme à l'incertitude
climatique s'ajoute celle des aides
comme beaucoup d'agriculteurs Quentin Le
Guillou dépend de la pâqu la politique
agricole commune qui repr représente 30
% du budget de l'Union européenne depuis
que je suis installé j'aurais peut-être
pu m'en passer peut-être 2 ans sur 8 que
je me suis
installé les autres fois bah comme cette
année heureusement que j'ai la pâack
parce que c'est quasiment la pâack qui
va faire mon salaire pour l'année et ça
c'est vraiment dommage parce que je suis
dans un système beaucoup plus vertueux
et je pense aujourd'hui pouvoir m'en
sortir malheureusement on a des des des
cours on est sur des marchés mondiaux et
et une concurrence européenne et
mondiale qui qui est très très forte
engagé au sein du syndicat des jeunes
agriculteurs Quentin Le Guillou réclame
surtout de la visibilité pour l'avenir
et des règles qui ne changent pas en
permanence pour ne pas décourager les
jeunes de s'installer alors que la
moitié des agriculteurs partira en
retraite d'ici
2030 voilà pour ce reportage de Jérôme
Rabier Jean-Philippe moanet finalement
ce portrait d'agriculteur illustre bien
les revendications actuelles de notre
secteur agcole dans ce mouvement de
grogne c'est-à-dire et bien la
difficulté de pouvoir vivre de son
travail avec des normes des prix
instable et finalement une une lourdeur
dans dans l'exercice de de ce beau
métier oui tout à fait le témoignage
était intéressant à plus plus d'un titre
d'ailleurs parce que il évoquait à la
fois les difficultés je crois qu'il faut
pas parler des agriculteurs en général a
il y a pas les agriculteurs il y a des
agriculteurs avec beaucoup de variétés
on a 400000 exploitations agricoes en
France euh on sait qu'il y a un/art de
ces exploitants agricoles qui sont en
difficulté voire en en très grave
difficulté mais il y a 3/4 de
l'agriculture qui se porte très bien la
l'agriculture française est la première
puissance agricole européenne euh alors
on voit les propagateurs aussi de contre
vérité sur l'Europe par exemple
qu'est-ce qu'on voit au niveau européen
le premier budget européen c'est la
politique agricole commune voulue par le
général de Gaulle qui a certes baisser
mais qui reste le tiers du budget
européen quand on entend dire il faut
moins d'Europe faut-il moins de
politique agricole commune qui bénéficie
aux agriculteurs à hauteur de 10
milliards 10 milliards d'euros chaque
année pour la
franceénire donc il y a des paradoxes
aussi dans cette problématique
l'agriculture il y a des vrais sujets
sur le quart de cette population
agricole qui est en grave difficulté
mais il faut pas mélanger tous les
sujets et puis y a le sujet
environnemental dont on parlera ah oui
beaucoup beaucoup d'aspects dans cette
crise agricole Michel d'Armon finalement
elle éclate en ce moment cette grogne
des agriculteurs mais ça fait des années
qu'on parle de leur malaise de leur
mal-être oui et puis ça fait des années
que les les les sujets restent
identiques en particulier effectivement
une fois qu'on a dressé effectivement
souligné la nuance de de de au sein du
monde agricole et les nuances qui
peuvent exister il n'en reste pas moins
que ce qui est permanent c'est le poids
des normes c'est la la le le la
bureaucratie permanente qui tombe de
plus en plus sur les agriculteurs depuis
depuis des années qui les empêche de
tout simplement de de de se développer
et c'est au fond ce qui me frappe dans
cette crise là et qui au fond raconte la
crise d'un nouveau monde c'est
l'affrontement avec les écologistes
parce que quand les Européens quand les
agriculteurs visent l'Europe
effectivement ils ne visent pas la
politique agricole commune il vise le
Green Deal il vise cette ce nouveau plan
qui est en train de se mettre en place
et qui effectivement vise à à
transformer complètement également le
rapport à leur production et qui veut
encadrer avec les normes écologiques
donc donc leur leur métier et on le voit
bien sur le terrain l'affrontement
nouveau il est de plus en plus patant
entre les écologistes et les
agriculteurs alors pour analyser cette
crise agricole on va retrouver un
sénateur qui est concerné par le sujet
puisqu'il est agriculteur de profession
on va retrouver Jean-Michel Arnaud
bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénateur
centriste des Hautes Alpes Jean-Michel
Arnaud d'abord votre analyse votre
constat notamment en partant du terrain
qu'est-ce qui ne va pas sur quel
le gouvernement doit apporter des
réponses pour et bien apaiser les
agriculteurs d'abord le malaise des
agriculteurs est lié à leur conditions
de vie leurs conditions de vie
économique leur relation au marché et le
fait que c'est extrêmement rare dans les
professions quel qu'ell soi c'est
finalement l'acheteur qui fait le prix
et et donc à un moment il n'est pas en
phase avec le prix de production plus
l'impact de la crise ukrainienne plus
les
difficultés liées aussi à l'apparition
finalement d'une sorte d'oligopole des
acheteurs avec des groupements
d'acheteurs qui font plus que jamais le
prix de la production on on sent
effectivement que les agriculteurs sont
au bord du gouffre et il le manifeste
avant de tomber dans le gouffre donc ce
que nous attendons est ce que je crois
nécessaire de la part du gouvernement
c'est d'abord de renouer le dialogue de
renouer un dialogue sur la méthode et
sur les objectifs sur la méthode c'est
considérer que il faut d'abord écouter
ceux qui font et pas simplement ceux qui
parlent et ceux qui font aujourd'hui
l'agriculture française ce qui contribue
à la souveraineté alimentaire française
et européenne ce sont les agriculteurs
et puis les objectifs c'est trouver les
moyens de baisser les coûts de
production des agriculteurs et dans tous
les cas à minima de faire en sorte que
les coûts de production de l'agriculture
française euh rejoignent ceux de leurs
concurrents intraeuropéen mais surtout
extraeuropéen dans des conditions
d'exercice et de production identique
c'est-à-dire que si les normes sont
imposés et il est normal de prendre en
compte d'abord la pétence des
consommateurs pour des productions
saines et puis la nécessité aussi de
travailler la transition écologique avec
le réchofement climatique il faut que
les règles soient effectivement
identiques pour toutes et tous ce qui
est perçu par les agriculteur comme
aujourd'hui une contreevérité enfin il y
a l'urgence immédiate euh le
gouvernement et
l'Europe sont nécessairement en dialogue
puisque ce sont des partagé entre la PAC
et les politiques local et il y a eu des
avancées je pense la prédation
particulièrement important dans mon
département la perspective du
déclassement du loup par exemple en
espace en espèce très protégé à protégé
permet d'avoir des marges de manœuvre
pour pouvoir réduire les problématiques
sur les productions d'élevage en
particulierich
pardz-moou pardonnez-moi je vais vous
couper je vais vous couper Jean-Michel
Arnaud pour évoquer un drame qui s'est
produit ce matin autour de ces blocages
d'agriculteur puisqu'une femme est
décédée dans le département de lariège
dans un accident de la route alors et
bien qu'elle et bien en fait voilà un
accident routier sur un barrage
d'agriculteur elle est décédée son mari
et sa fille sont blessé on va écouter la
réaction à ce drame du président du S
agricole la FNSA je viens d'apprendre
qu'un accident de la route est arrivé
dans l'Arriège à Pamier et que trois de
nos adhérents ont subi un grave accident
une femme est décédée son mari et sa
fille sont dans un
état compliqué visiblement et pris en
charge
rapidement par l'ensemble des services
de du
Samu dans le moment particulier que
villeagriculture ce genre de drame est
difficile à vivre et donc je voudrais
d'abord dire aux gens qui sont sont sur
le terrain qui on a ils ont le plein
soutien de de de de l'ensemble des
agriculteurs français ce drame il vient
souligner la nécessité qu'on a d'être
parfaitement organisé de faire en sorte
de respecter encore une fois les les
consignes de sécurité parce que ce qui
est important pour nous c'est de faire
passer nos messages Jean-Michel Arnaud
une réaction à ce drame et est-ce que
maintenant et bien Géraldo Darmanin le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui refusait
jusque-l et bien de déloger ces
agriculteurs est-ce qu'il doit ordonner
l'évacuation de ces barrages routiers
pour des raisons de sécurité d'abord une
pensée pour évidemment cette famille
d'agriculteur et au-delà pour tous les
agriculteurs de France qui sont exposés
à des difficultés majeures et je
rappelle que le taux de suicide chez les
agriculteurs est très élevé donc
évidemment je partage cette tristesse
pour le reste on a besoin aussi de
syndicat responsable de syndicat qui
canalise la colère et les revendications
des agriculteurs pour éviter évidemment
des drames liés à l'inorganisation ou
l'exposition à des risques euh insensés
à l'occasion de ces manifestations d'où
l'importance immédiate d'une reprise de
dialogue forte concrète avec des
propositions avec le gouvernement et
avec la Commission et l'Union européenne
pour lever les tensions et faire en
sorte qu'il n'y ait pas un embrasement
du pays qui ne générerait que du malheur
et probablement générerait des positions
de récupération politique inaccepable
parce que euh le combat des agriculteurs
ne doit pas être un combat de
récupération politique à des fins
d'élections européennes la question est
trop importante pour que elle dérive
cette manière je fais confiance au
syndicats tous les syndicats de France
pour essayer de canaliser cette colère
l'organiser et obtenir du gouvernement
et de l'Union européenne des réponses
concrètes sur la question des normes sur
la question de la rémunération et sur
une discussion au long
termedire des conditions des conditions
d'exploitation des des fermes françaises
européennes JeanMichel ARN je vais
donner la parole à mes invités sur ce
plateau Michel d'mont une réaction à ce
drame ça y est il y a un mort dans cette
crise agricole est-ce qu'on entre dans
une dans une nouvelle dimension dans une
crise qui était déjà sensible pour le
gouvernement bah il faudra d'abord
établir effectivement les exactement les
circonstances s' s'agit d'un
accident il faut espérer évidemment que
ça ne rajoute pas à la tension ambiante
ça se rappelle tristement également le
le premier acte des gilets jaunes en
novembre 2018 qui avait également
démarré par le le le décès d'une
automobiliste qui voulait forcer forcer
un barrage on verra effectivement dans
quelles circonstances s'est passé ce que
je retiens de l'intervention également
de votre sénateur lorsqu'il appelle au
calme en disant il faut que il y ait un
éviter qu'il a des tensions aussi au
niveau de la mobilisation je pense qu'il
fait aussi allusion au fait qu'il a
quand même une très forte tension entre
les organisations syndicales sur le
terrain puisque il y a quand même une
pression de la Coordination rurale qui
est le syndicat
rival plus radical sur sur sur le
terrain que la FNSEA qui crée des
rapports de force mais qui accompagne
quand même le le pouvoir est toujours
suspecté d'un peu d'accompagner le
pouvoir parce que sur le terrain
justement les actions militantes sont
aussi à l'initiative de la Coordination
Rurale Jean-Philippe moet l'urgence pour
le gouvernement c'est certes d'apporter
des réponses aux agriculteur mais
surtout là de faire baisser la tension
oui bien sûr parce que en fait les
tensions quand elles sont radicalisées
n'apportent rien ell les aggrave les
problèmes posés donc on voit bien qu'il
y a des tensions qui peuvent se créer si
les difficultés coméhensible et
légitimement euh mise en avant par
certains agriculteurs provoquent des
tensions au point de mettre en
difficulté je ne sais pas quelles sont
les circonstances de cette ce ce drame
euh mais s mettre en difficulté d'autres
citoyens qui sont en difficulté par
rapport à leur emploi pour aller
circuler normalement euh vers leur
emploi par exemple c'est c'est un souci
donc on voit bien que certains aussi
sont les exploitants des difficultés et
des peurs il y a les grand les
exploitants agricoles et a les grands
exploitants des protestations
radicalisées en France on voit bien on
est servi pour ça dans dans notre pays
par rapport à d'autres pays euh donc il
faut pas avoir une tendance à la
confusion on voit bien que les extrêmes
aussi ont tendance à ressortir du bois
pour exploiter un certain nombre de
difficulté euh il faut poser les
problèmes tels qu'ils sont Michel
darmond tout à l'heure évoqué à juste
titre la question des tracasseries
administratives qui est un vrai sujet il
y a le sujet des normes par ailleurs
qu'il faudra aborder parce que
derailleurs les normes il y a beaucoup
de choses qui sont utiles pour l'Europe
et la France à savoir les normes
sanitaires parce que la santé publique
c'est pas rien et les Français sont
attentifs à la santé publique aussi donc
les normes on peut mettre aussi beaucoup
de choses derrière l' normme on va
évoquer les différents aspects de cette
crise agricole notamment l'angle
européen dans dans quelques minutes car
on va voir que cette crise cette grogne
elle se passe dans d'autres pays
européens mais d'abord on va vous voir
une autre réaction à ce drame en Ariège
alors voilà on on verra dans quelques
instants on présise dans l'oreillette
une réaction du président du Sénat à ce
décès d'une femmees en arriè sur un
barrage routier d'agriculteur alors je
disais cette crise agricole est
française mais Audrey elle est également
européenne on va voir que un peu partout
dans l'Union et bien il y a des
tracteurs qui bloquent des autoroutes
qui bloquent des centr-villes et on a
l'impression que ce mécontentement
agricole finalement il se propage dans
tout le continent oui ça a commencé au
Pays-Bas avant de gagner l'Autriche
l'Espagne la Roumanie la Belgique
l'Allemagne et donc maintenant la France
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'à
l'origine ces contestations partent
toutes d'un fait national aux Pays-Bas
par exemple c'est la suppression de
certaines exploitations agricoles à
cause de la pollution au nitrite qui est
très présente dans le pays en Allemagne
c'est la fin d'une niche fiscale sur le
carburant agricole et en France c'est le
projet notamment de loi d'installation
des nouveaux agriculteurs qui pose
problème mais le phénomène semble faire
tachche d'huile et les agriculteurs
européens se sont trouvés un etnemi
commun l'Union européenne et ses normes
écoutz cette agricultrice allemande et
ensuite cette agriculteur
français règ bureaucratiqu sont de plus
en plus nombreuses et nous en avons
assez nous voulons simplement faire
notre travail et ne pas rester assis
dans un bureau toute la journée à
remplir divers papiers c'est pour ça que
nous sommes
ici adistratif et
règlementaire qui font que on est pas
compétitif et qu'on produit à trop c'est
trop cher et on est obligé voyez bien
d'importer de la viande pleinin de
choses qui étrangers moin
cher alors le principal point de
crispation ce sont les normes
environnementales imposées par l'Union
européenne qui veut vous le savez que le
continent soit neutre en carbone d'ici
2050 l'agriculture est responsable de 20
% des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
il y a donc des mesures pour changer ces
pratiques même s'il faut souligner qu'il
y a aussi des aides pour changer ces
pratiques des aides qui font de la
paperace aussi on sait par exemple que
pour un agriculteur les normes
environnementales et le la papprace
l'administratif qui doit faire autour
c'est à peu près un jour par semaine en
moyenne donc on voit que c'est quand
même c'est quand même impressionnant en
en de règle en règle générale pardon les
agriculteurs ont aussi l'impression
d'être en concurrence déloyale avec les
produits importés de l'étranger il voi
d'un très mauvais œil par exemple le
futur traité UE Mercosur un traité
commercial ou encore l'arrivée de
l'Ukraine dans l'Union européenne
l'Ukraine qui est le grenier céréalier
de l'Europe et ça les politiques le
prennent très au sérieux oui benah
regardez la France a déjà reporté
l'examen du projet de loi sur
l'installation des nouveaux agriculteurs
qui posent problème beaucoup craignent
un retour des gilets jaunes ou une
contestation qui s'étendrait au niveau
européen en tout cas le mal-être des
agriculteurs va sûrement devenir un
sujet pour ces élections européennes car
la droite conservatrice et l'extrême
droite mise sur ce vote agricoolle et
puis peut-être petite anecdote ça s'est
passé l'été dernier et il y a déjà eu
une hystérisation des débats autour des
sujets agricoles ça concernait un texte
pour défendre la biodiversité et on
avait vu des manifestations assez
virulentes d'agriculteur devant le
Parlement européen ça se passé au
Parlement européen la venue de Gret
tenenberg pour les écologistes donc on
voit que c'est quand même un sujet très
preignant au niveau européen merci
beaucoup audrait Jean-Michel Arnaud une
réaction on le voit cette crise agricole
elle se propage dans plusieurs pays
européens est-ce que ça veut dire que
l'Union Européenne a une responsabilité
dans cette situation
elle a une part de responsabilité bien
naturellement puisque le principal
revenu d'aide des agriculteurs est
constitué par la politique agricole
commune ceci étant dit je crois que
accuser l'Union européenne et les
institutions européennes des mots qui
existent dans nos territoires ruraux
serait évidemment un raccourci
euh vraiment malsin parce que euh
évidemment les difficultés que nous
avons sont lié essentiellement à la
relation que nous avons avec le reste du
monde et avoir un marché interne
organisé sur les normes que nous
définissons nous et faire en sorte que
les clauses miroirs puissent se mettre
en mouvement pour que euh final
finalement nos importations extérieures
quand c'est nécessaire se fassent sur la
base de nos normes européennes de
protection du consommateur me paraît
effectivement nécessaire par ailleurs je
crois qu'il est important aussi que les
agriculteurs fassent entendre leur voix
parce que la question aussi des
transitions lié au réchauffement
climatique impacte pas seulement les
agriculteurs mais particulement les
agriculteurs et toutes les adaptations
et toutes les accompagnements financiers
qui en découlent ne peut pas se faire
sans eux donc moi j'un appelle à à à une
discussion nourrie et à à une
négociation sur les perspectives
peut-être plus étalées dans le temps de
contribution de l'agriculture européenne
à l'effort nécessaire lié au
réchauffement climatique tout en
respectant évidemment le le travail des
agriculteurs je rappelle qu'il travaille
pour un grandre 4550 par semaine
évidemment c'est respectable je vais
faire circuler la parole la donnée à
Jean-Philippe moineet est-ce que c'est
pas un peu facile c'est pas un raccourci
de dire voilà comme l'a fait Jordan
Bardella là c'est la faute de l'Europe
oui non seulement c'est car l'Europe
apporte quand même beaucoup aux
agriculteurs avec toutes ses toutes ces
aides avec cette politique agricole
commune oui c'est c'est non seulement un
raccourci mais une démagogie assez
récurrente concernant cette formation
politique mais c'est vrai que qu'est-ce
qu'on veut pour l'Europe est-ce qu'on
veut que l'Europe soit plus vertueuse en
matière de protection de la santé
publique parce qu'on sait que des
productions agricole
étrangère voyons la Chine comment s
produit voyons l'Amérique du Sud avec
est-ce qu'on veut des piqures aux
hormones pour la production agricole
française évidemment non donc il y a la
protection des consommateurs des
citoyens passe par un peu plus de normes
sanitaires première chose deuxième chose
sur l'aspect environnemental qui sont
les victimes de du réchauffement
climatiqu est-ce que ce sont pas aussi
voir surtout les agriculteurs donc il y
a aussi des des confusions dans dans les
objectifs après ça soit aménager pour
une transition acceptable et acceptée et
surtout positive pour une partie des
agriculteurs qui souffrre
particulièrement évidemment oui d'où la
politique européenne qui est encore une
fois le premier budget de l'Europe c'est
l'agriculture le premier pays a
bénéficié de la la PAC c'est la France
donc arrêtons de jeter le bébé avec
l'eau du bain euh il faut mettre les
choses à plat voir quels sont les
problèmes qui se posent en terme de
tracasserie administrative ce qui est
totalement légitime il faut aider les
petits exploitants qui ont pas les
moyens de service juridique important
notamment par des fédérations agricoles
de elon les les différences aussi de
secteur parce que l'agriculture c'est
aussi soit l'élevage ça peut être la
production céréalière c'est très
différent selon les secteurs et
l'agroalimentaire en France se porte
très bien en terme d'exportation aussi
donc il faut pas aussi caricaturer la
situation qui est plus complexe que
certains veulent le présenter Michel
Darmon sur le plan politique on sent
bien que cette question de l'aide aux
agriculteurs de la politique européenne
pour l'agriculture ça va être un sujet
majeur dans la campagne des européennes
la campagne campagne européenne a
commencé c'est sur le terrain
effectivement de l'agriculture puisquen
plus qu'on voit queil s'agit d'une
révolte européenne on l'a signalé he
chacune pour ses raisons nationales mais
en même temps qui se propage à travers à
travers toute l'Europe je crois que le
le le mouvement auquel est confronté
aujourd'hui le gouvernement peut
effectivement s'apparenter à une sorte
de de gilet vert qui a commencé
d'illeurs déjà depuis quelques semaines
sous les radars complètement de
l'actualité avec le mouvement on marche
sur la tête qui renversa c'est notre
commune enversé rversé c'est une sorte
de de de de révolte douce on va dire
mais évidemment comme les pouvoirs
publics ne réagissent que sous la
contrainte il a fallu pour les
agriculteurs monter monter d'un cran
bien sûr il y a la question européenne
bien sûr il y a la question avec les
écologistes on l' signalé mais il y a
surtout également la la je dirais cette
maladie de norme et de la
bureaucratisation française 14
réglementation régissent le le le la
culture de la haie en France dans les
ivelines vous avez encore le le le
décret sécheresse alors qu'il y a eu 2
mois de pluie et et au fond les
agriculteurs ne peuvent pas travailler
comme ils veulent parce qu'ils sont sous
le couvert du décret sécheresse donc
quand vous entendez ce genre de
effectivement d'exemples qui sont loin
des grands discours et des grandes
incantation des des élus qui souvent n'y
connaissent rien et bien c'est là la la
la la la raison de la colère des
agriculteurs et si c'est des réponses
précises à ce type de de situation
ubuesque n'est pas sont pas trouvé et
bien ce mouvement continuera à à
s'implanterra et justement ça fait
partie des points de sortie de crise
évoqué par le gouvernement de
simplification justement et en fait le
gouvernement propose d'éviter
l'empilement des normes notamment au
sujet des agriculteurs pour éviter qu'on
se retrouve avec une douzaine de textes
pour réglement dans quelle mesure le
système sera capable de pouvoir mais qui
été proposé comme sortie de crise il y a
le problème des norm il y a aussi le
problème d'une taxe comme dans la crise
des gilets jaunes comme lors de la
révolte des Bonou rouge il y a une
hausse de taxes écologique qui provoque
la colère dans ce mouvement de grogne
c'est une hausse de taxe sur le gazol
non routier Jean-Michel Arnaud est-ce
que Gabriel Atal le chef du gouvernement
doit abandonner cette hausse de taxe sur
le gazol pour les
agriculteurs dans tous les cas il faut
travailler à l'allègement des charges et
le principal poste notamment pour les
agriculteur d'exploitation à taille
humaine c'est effectivement le le le
génère le le gazol non routier et je
pense qu'il faut à minima lisser la
haosse et accompagner les agriculteurs
sur l'allèement d'autres charges par
exemple les charges de la MSA qui sont
évidemment un élément important de
protection sociale sert des agriculteurs
et des salairies agricoles mais surtout
un élément de charge au quotidien
insupportable et si vous me le permettez
pour réagir au propos du politologue je
pense que il faut également avoir une
déconcentration aussi des pouvoirs de
décision de l'administration
centrale vers les territoires sur la
question de ce qu'on appelle les
bassines ou plus exactement les réserves
stratégiques d'eau avoir un préfet qui a
davantage la main pour coordonner les
services déconcentrés de l'État pour
faciliter les procédures de gestion des
autorisations de création de ces
réserves d'eau faciliterait probablement
allégerait la charge des agriculteurs et
détendraer le monde agricole dans les
territoires on voit très bien que ce
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui donc
finalement ce que le Sénat porte
régulièrement en matière de
déconcentration en matière de
décentralisation devrait évidemment
s'appliquer aussi à l'agriculture pour
créer des relations de proximité des
relations de confiance de proximité
entre les décideurs le monde rural et
particulièrement les agriculteurs une
réaction oui au-delà de du sujet qui est
un vrai sujet des taxes sur le gasoil
non routier il peut y avoir des
allègements des accompagnements mais il
y a le sujet dont pas beaucoup de monde
parle c'est le sujet des prix et
notamment de les effort qui est prêt ou
pas à consentir le consommateur citoyen
est-ce que nous français on est prêt à
payer
davantage les produits alimentaires pour
les agriculteurs c'est une vraie
question on a chacun une responsabilité
quand on fait des achats et on voit bien
qu'il y a la pression contradictoire
entre la la lutte contre enfin la la
promotion du pouvoir d'achat des
consommateurs donc limiter l'inflation
mais aussi parfois consentir à à aider
les productions françaises en matière
d'agriculture la production bio euh
voilà il y a des arbitrages qui sont
aussi qui est du ressort des citoyens et
consommateur do doit jouer un rôle aussi
pour aiderou la grande distribution il y
a eu un Pact à un moment donné pour
soutenir les agriculteurs où est-ce
qu'il en est aujourd'hui il faudrait
peut-être remettre les distributeurs
aussi sur le chantier peut-être de la
d'une hausse limitée mais d'une un
maintien de du cours de certains
produits alimentaires qui sont vitaux
pour certains agriculteurs alors je le
disais l'information du qu'on a appris
ce matin c'est le décès de cette femme
dans un accident routier sur un barrage
d'agriculteur dans le départ appartement
de larriège on va écouter la réaction du
président du Sénat jaralarcher à ce
drame c'est un drame c'est un drame et
mais penser Bont d'abord à ceux qui
aujourd'hui sont en train de se battre
pour la vie et à cette femme qui est
décédé et face à ce drame il importe que
les réponses soient très vite apportées
au monde agricole vous savez il y a
longtemps que nous sentions la montée de
cette tension au Sénat nous avions voté
une proposition de loi sur la
compétitivité de la ferme France nous
avions fait des rapports nous attirions
l'attention du gouvernement à l'époque
d'Élisabeth borne maintenant nous disons
il y a
urgence voilà pour cette réaction du
président du Sénat à ce décès on va
finir par toujours en évoquant cette
crise agricole voir la revue de presse
de nos
territoires
et Audrey la colère des agriculteurs qui
fait la une de nos quotidiens régionaux
ce matin oui très largement regardez une
grande partie de la presse on empar
encore ce matin aux quatre coins de la
France à chacun son titre he pour
l'ardonné c'est l'exaspération des
agriculteurs pour Corse Matin
agriculteur l'épreuve d'une vie pour le
Courrier Picard la fronde atteint la
région d'Amien et ça continue
agriculture entre malaise et mutation
pour les Dernières Nouvelles d'Alsace La
Dépêche du Midi elle se penche sur le
cas Gabriel hatal le premier ministre
face à la colère des agriculteurs il
faut dire que c'est sa première crise
politique depuis qu'il a été nommé il a
d'ailleurs reçu hier on l'a dit he les
responsables les principaux responsables
syndicaux et enfin je termine par un
très bon titre que j'ai relevé de
Sud-Ouest les racines de la colère et
Audrey d'autres professions pourraient
se joindre à la colère des agriculteurs
c'est en tout cas ce qu'espèrent les
pêcheurs du Golfe de gasconne regardez
c'est en uneun du télégramme qui titre
la terre gronde et la mer grogne des
pêcheurs qui doivent rester à qu pendant
un mois vous le savez euh pour éviter
les prises accidentelles de dauphin même
s'ils seront aidés financièrement c'est
du jamais vu depuis 1945 alors
l'inquiétude est grande les pêcheurs ont
prévu de se rendre à Rennes jeudi pour
unir leur voix à celle des agriculteurs
et puis je termine par une belle
histoire c'est en Une de l'INE nouvell
et j'ai relevé qu'à 100 ans Félix Fievez
a toujours la flamme cet habitant de
mondorinist pour terminer sur une bonne
note sera l'un des relais de la flamme
olympique le 17 juillet prochain bon
pied bon œil he le centenaire et si vous
voulez son secret c'est la course à pied
il a gagné 15 fois le cross du Figaro
une passion qu'il s'est découvert au
sortir de la guerre donc voilà en
juillet tout le village de mondorini
aura les yeux rivés sur sa fierté locale
merci beaucoup audreet pour cette revue
de presse des territoire qui est clos ce
club des territoires qui finalement a
été entièrement consacré à cette crise
agricole qui touche notre pays et qui
touche également toute le toute l'Europe
merci beaucoup Jean-Michel Arnaud
sénateur centriste des Hautes Alpes et
Agri ulteur de profession d'avoir
participé à ce club des territoires
merci beaucoup Michel darmond d'être
venu merci Jean-Philippe moineet et j'en
j'en profite pour citer votre roman un
journal sous influence qui évoque et
bien une histoire dans les coulisses
sombres de la politique française une
rédaction et passionné et ça parle
également de de journalisme merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir suivi cette
émission à 18h ce sera votre émission
votre rendez-vous sans public présenté
par Thomas HUG et puis quant à nous on
se retrouve demain à 17h30 très bonne
journée sur public
scénna la presse quotidienne régionale
et les télévisions locales vous ont
présenté le club des
[Musique]
territoires